die AFD in Ostdeutschland ich habe
vorhin Martin machobetz zitiert und wir
haben jetzt schon mehrfach gesagt und
daraus resultiert ja auch die Sorge
sozusagen um um ja um die Demokratie um
es mal so groß zu machen bei ihn Herr
machobetz sagen wir haben diese drei
Wahlen das sind Wahlen das sind
schicksalswahlen für dieses ganze Land
und sie sagen das Schicksal der CDU wird
sich vor allen Dingen in Sachsen
entscheiden und es wird die Debatte
sagen sie auf die Union zukommen und
wenn man sich die umfrageerte ansieht
dann ahnt man dass das passieren wird
wie machen wir es denn jetzt eigentlich
könnte es theoretisch passieren oder was
müsste passieren dass jemand wie z.B
Björn höcke Ministerpräsident von
Thüringen wird könnte das passieren also
dass ich die Zukunft der CDU oder
zumindest ähm die die die kurzfristigere
Zukunft der CDU in Sachsen entscheidet
liegt ja schon daran dass das das
einzige der drei Bundesländer ist die
nächstes in den nächstes Jahr gewählt
wird oder in diesem Jahr gewählt wird
indem die CDU tatsächlich regiert ähm
und die Frage ob sie in Sachsen von der
AFD geschlagen wird obwohl sie dann ein
Ministerpräsidenten hat der in den
letzten Jahren wirklich alles getan hat
äh um die AFD irgendwie kleiner zu
machen einzuschmelzen
sich hier in den Weg zu stellen manchmal
auch sehr sehr bewusst gegen das was er
in Berlin wahrnimmt oder in Europa
wahrnimmt ähm sich dagegen zu stellen
und einen eigenen Ton zu finden er hat
in der Debatte um den ukrainekrieg und
Russland häufig eine andere Position
gehabt in der Debatte um Gaspipelines
häufig eine andere
Position gehabt er hat sich bei Corona
häufig ein bisschen anders positioniert
und immer so wie er glaubte dass ein
cdu-pitiker eben in Sachsen sein muss
und wenn selbst der jetzt da scheitert
äh dann wäre das für diese Partei schon
ein ziemlich großes Problem äh und was
die CDU äh und deswegen ist es ähm auch
eine große Frage mit der dies diese
Partei sich jetzt glaube ich
beschäftigen muss bevor diese Wahlen
kommen für sich klären muss ist einmal
das Verhältnis zur AFD schon klar das
wird noch mal wirklich interessant wenn
die Wahlergebnisse da sind aber auch das
Verhältnis zu zur Linken und
möglicherweise auch das Verhältnis zur
neuen Partei von Sara Wagenknecht weil
es gut sein kann dass wir nach diesen
Landtagswahlen vor Konstellation stehen
in den eine Regierung
nur möglich ist wenn die CDU mit beiden
oder einer dieser beiden Parteien
zusammenarbeitet und in Thüringen haben
wir haben wir eine ganz besonders
Defizite Lage die AFD könnte mit BN
höcke stärkste Kraft werden wir haben
den stehen bei 34%ehen deutlich über
30%. wir haben einen linken
Ministerpräsident der nur
Ministerpräsidenten der mit seiner
Partei nur knapp über 20 steht auch die
CDU bewegt sich in diesem Bereich es
könnte also sein dass wir dann eine
starke AFD haben stärkste Kraft dann
haben wir vielleicht die CDU auf Platz 2
mit 23% und vielleicht haben wir brudo
ramelo auf Platz 3 mit 20% und die Linke
und dann muss sie dann dann wird eine
Dynamik ausbrechen und eine dann werden
Kräfte wirken an dieser Partei ähm die
so stark sind dass man auf diesen Moment
besser schon vorbereitet ist wenn er
kommt also dann wird sich die CDU
einfach entscheiden müssen ob sie um
diese Demokratie am Leben und lebendig
zu halten mit der Linkspartei
zusammenarbeitet bisher ist das per
Satzung ausgeschlossen mhm ähm und der
Tag der Wahl und der Tag des
Wahlergebnisses ist der eine Tag an dem
es zu spät ist sich darüber Gedanken
gemacht zu haben wie man damit umgehen
will und deswegen würde ich sagen eine
der wichtigsten Demokratie theoretischen
staatspolitischen Aufgaben die die CDU
jetzt noch bis zum Herbst hat ist eine
offene Debatte zu führen darüber wie Sie
mit der AFD umgeht im Fall eines solchen
Wahlergebnis aber auch ob sie äh diesen
rigorosen Ausschluss einer
Zusammenarbeit mit der Linkspartei auf
Landesebene fortführen möchte und
vielleicht möchte ja Herr spanen heute
abend diese Debatte ja ich ich geb ihm
noch 10 Sekunden Zeit um darüber
nachzudenken würd gerne Herr quen vorher
fragen was könnte denn da passieren was
müsste eintreten damit jemand wie börn
höcke z.B wer das denkbar
Ministerpräsident börn höcke in
Thüringen das ist nicht mehr nicht
vorstellbar ja und das würde ich auch
historisch nicht auf Thüringen
beschränken wir sind jetzt ganz konkret
aber ich meine schauen wir in die
Niederlande schauen wir nach Italien an
anderen äh in andere Lände vor vor vor
so einer rechtsradikalisierung sind im
Moment keine Gesellschaften sicher aber
schauen wir nach Thüringen es könnte
theoretisch passieren dass im dritten
Wahlgang wenn es keinen stärkeren
Gegenkandidaten gibt und die AFD
stärkste Kraft ist die letztlich aus
eigener Kraft höcke zum
Ministerpräsident weil dann im dritten
Wahlgang die einfache Mehrheit reicht
exakt wenn nicht eine andere
Konstellation andere Kandidaten antreten
ja also theoretisch gibt es durchaus
Möglichkeiten Modelle auf die man sich
vorbereiten muss auf die man sich
vorbereiten sollte äh es gibt andere
Szenarien die man schlechter kalkulieren
kann was passiert wenn die FDP und wenn
die Grünen nicht wieder in den Landtag
einziehen dann stehen sind die
Größenverhältnisse sowieso noch mal
geordnet und die Frage selbst wenn es
sozusagen eine Regierungen wie auch
immer geartet gegen die AFD geben sollte
wird auch das die demokratische Kultur
nicht besser machen und wird nicht für
eine Demokratisierung von Verhältnissen
sondern für eine zu einer Zuspitzung
sorgen und ich möchte möchte noch mal
hervorheben dass wir gerade wenn wir
über Thüringen sprechen sprechen wir
nicht über eine ein bisschen
rechtspopulistische Partei wir sprechen
über eine auch vom Verfassungsschutz als
gesichert rechtsextrem und zwar nicht
weil sie die Regierung kritisieren
irgendwie und über die und populistisch
über die strengnge schlagen sondern weil
dahinter ein völkisch nationalistisches
Weltbild steht das kerntha ist Migration
eine ethnisch homogene Volksgemeinschaft
herzustellen das ist anschlussfähig an
all die Krisen Themen und Probleme die
stattfinden aber es ist ein qualitativer
Unterschied zu all den anderen Debatten
die wir haben dass wir dass wir hier
haben und des deswegen wird ja auch über
die Möglichkeit eines AFD
verbotverfahrens diskutiert es gibt
Offenheit bei Herrn Günther habe ich
zuletzt
gelesen wir haben die diese diese
aggressive Situation um die Existenz der
Demokratie die wir auch vor dem
Hintergrund führen müssen dass die
bundesdeutsche Demokratie ja nicht
irgendeine ist sondern eben eine
whrhafte und diese whrhaftigkeit aus den
Behörden aus den Parteien aus der
Zivilgesellschaft aber im Zweifelsfall
eben auch mit den juristischen Mitteln
auch das kann man nicht mehr
ausschließen und muss offen diskutieren
deshalb spannend die Frage wie halten
Sie es mit der Linkspartei na ja also es
war jetzt relativ viele Themen des
vielleicht noch mal sag was zu
Linkspartei keine Sorge was ich
bemerkenswert fand ist dass jetzt in
beiden Herleitungen die drei
ampelparteien im Grunde keine Rolle
gespielt haben also ich finde es
schon in Sachsen und fast unter der 5%
in der ersten Umfrage deswegen muss man
doch schon geht's um die auch nicht mehr
na ja aber man muss auch einmal schon
die Frage stellen ich frage mich
gelegentlich ob in diesen ampelparteien
sich überhaupt noch jemand die
frageestellt ich warte ja darauf dass
die aber die sind ja heute nicht hier ja
aber frage ich frage ich Ralf Stegner Kü
lar kling will aber doch nur mal darauf
hinweisen dass die christlich
demokratische Union in den drei Ländern
in denen gewäht in brandburg ist etwas
anders aber jedenfalls sicher in thürgen
und in Sachsen die einzige politische
Kraft in der Demokratischen Mitte ist
die über me Thema deswegen kommt es so
sehr auf sie
an ger wi machen es kommt vor allem
darauf an dass diese Ampel dass diese
Regierung eine Politik macht die doch
die Frage ist doch warum die stellt
überhaupt keiner mehr das finde ich
immer so beeindruckend hier niemand
warum ist die AFD so ST warum stellen
wir uns die Frage und sie
offestell auch
was Vergangenheit tun Minister im
Kabinett Merkel noch Monate bis Z kte
ich schau gerade nach vorne bis dahin
könnte man ja Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen ist ja nicht so dass die
Stimmung zur AFD zu allererst zu Lasten
der CDU geht nicht so dass die
CDU-Wähler in Scharen zur AFD gehen
sondern wir sehen ja vor allem bei der
SPD aber auch bei den anderen
ampelparteien einen massiven
Vertrauensverlust und deswegen würde ich
deswegen sie gerne in die nächste
Sendung bitte
ein mit der Antwort auf diese so simple
Frage ich leite sie doch gerade her ich
verstehe ich verstehe Ihre Sendung immer
Tempo und sie haben gerne Tempo ist
alles
okayte gerade machen ist hart an der
Grenze zur Ablenkung ne ist ne ich B ich
bin irritiert darüber dass darüber nicht
gesprochen
wird der zweite Teil der zweite Teil ist
der zweite Teil ist für Thüringen z.B
hat Mario fog der deutige
Spitzenkandidat der eine gute Arbeit der
mit
der na ja also wir können jetzt mal mit
diesen Begriffen ja ja bitte ist noch
nie mein Begriff hat hat ihr CD
vorsitzend in Thüringen Begriff okay ein
bisschen überspitzt aber das nicht
dramatisch da haben wir schon ganz
andere Dinge mir am Kopf geworfen
gekriegt von allen anderen hören wir do
mal auf mit dem ganzen Krams die Frage
ist gibt's eine wenn sie nicht passt
sagen sie hören mal auf mit dem Krams
gib nee geht um die eigentliche Frage
die haben sie mir gerade gestellt was
die Mehrheit nein die
mehrheitsperspektive hat Mario Fogt
gesagt ist in Absprache mit diesen
beiden Parteien dafür zu werben dass es
eine deutschlandkoalition gibt also
Union SPD liberal haben die aktuell in
den Umfragen eine Mehrheit nein eben
aber dafür ist ja Wahlkampf da ich bin
schon in viele Wahlen gestartet wie
andere Wahlkämpfer auch wo man am Anfang
noch keine Mehrheit hat wo man dann aber
mit Argumenten doch also wenn wir jetzt
schon den Kampf aufgeben und gar nicht
mehr daran glauben dass die
demokratische Mitte Mehrheit schaffen
kann in Thüring Sachsen Brandenburg dann
können wir tatsächlich einpacken ich bin
der festen Überzeugung man
kanntwort auf die simple Frage haben
wenn die Mehrheitsverhältnisse so sind
wie sie sich gerade in Umfragen abbilden
und nicht nur in einer sondern quasi
zementiert was bedeutet das es geht ja
schlicht um die Frage die Kollegen von
am Sonntag haben die vor einiger Zeit
mal gestellt wird Ostdeutschland
unregierbar und damit gemeint war genau
dieses Szenario wird dann nicht
unregierbar wenn wir schaffen in der
politischen Mitte wieder Mehrheiten zu
bilden und die K man nur bilden wenn man
Vertrauen Michael kretschm michel
kretschm ist der einzige ja die einz
tatsächliche Bollwerk in Sachsen der Tag
und Nacht arbeitet rackt das Gespräch
mit den Leuten sucht und alles dafür tut
dass Vertrauen zurückkommen kann und ich
will mir manchmal fr mir manchmal
wünschen dass diejenigen wenn ich dann
die die Eskens dieser Welt hören die
immer schlau in Berlin reden wenn die
sich mal genauso durch Sachsen ackern
würden um mitzuhelfen dass wir Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen das ist der entscheidende
Punk ich möchte nicht über irgendwelche
wahlumf wir bilden keine Koalition auf
der Basis von
wahlumfragenau gerade Wähler WählerInnen
schauen auch
zu ich verstehe das ja sogar ich
verstehe sogar dass her span vor der
Wahl ungern darüber diskutieren möchte
dar
Disk ich verstehe nicht ich verstehe
schon ich verstehe schon dass sie ung
darüber diskutier möchten wie jetzt das
Verhältnis zur Linkspartei ausschaut
weil das erstens für die CDU eine
wahnsinnig gefährliche Frage ist sich
vor der Wahl einen in der Nähe der
Linkspartei auszusetzen das ist
irgendwie strategisch nicht das
schlauste das ist mir schon total klar
wenn sie jetzt sagen würden wir müssen
nach der Wahl schon drüber nachdenken ob
wir mit dieser Partei zusammenarbeiten
können dann ist
das dann ist das für sie strategisch
gefährlich aber warum ist er überhaupt
noch im Amt
aber wahig nett wenn ich diesen Gedanken
einmal kurz zu Ende führen dürfte
ähm es ist keine strategische Frage mehr
über die wir jetzt sprechen wir sprechen
die CDU ist die Partei der
staatspolitischen Verantwortung die hat
jahrzehntelang Stabilität in die
Bundesrepublik gebracht die war die
Partei die mehrere dieser ostdeutschen
Bundesländer aufs hervorragendste
aufgebaut hat nach 1990 Sachsen und
Thüringen zu
vorderst diese Partei muss sich jetzt
fragen ihre Partei muss ich jetzt fragen
ob sie in der Lage sein möchte nach
diesem Wahltag einen entscheidenden
Beitrag zur Rettung dies Demokratie und
dieses demokratischen Prozesses zu
leisten und diesen Beitrag wird sie nur
leisten können wenn sie dann einen Plan
hat und diesen Plan müssen sie heute
machen egal ob sie noch z%pkte kosten
könnte und ich frage mich halt wirklich
seit vielen vielen Jahren schon warum
diese Debatte nie geführt wird am
Wahltag haben wir dann oft Ergebnisse
die irgendwie alle verwirren und dann
passieren solche Sachen wie diese
kämerichwahl also überhaupt keine
strategische Ausrichtung in den
Landesverbänden die Partei sieht da
passiert irgendwas was wir gerade nicht
steuern können die Landtagsfraktion
machen irgendwas in ihrer Hektik und in
ihrer Panik und das was sie dann tun
regt in Berlin wieder alle auf und dann
kommt es zu so einem Clash wie den den
wir damals erlebt haben und dann steht
eine Kanzlerin in Südafrika und sagt
diese Wahl muss rückgängig gemacht
werden ich würde mich wahnsinnig freuen
wenn wir dieses Szenario einfach
vermeiden würden indem wir heute schon
drüber diskutieren
wie noch mal ganz kurz um das zu
präzisieren was her ma gerade gesagt die
ganz simple Frage schließen Sie eine
Zusammenarbeit mit der Linkspartei eine
Zusammenarbeit mit der
sarawagenrechtpartei oder auch eine
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD aus letzteres
haben wir ausgeschlossen ist weiterhin
also die also Linke nicht ausgeschlossen
heißt das also ihr versucht immer wieder
von der gleichen Richtung also ich kann
jetzt was wir zur AFD seit Jahren sagen
ich habe ich habe Bücher von börn höcke
gelesen dann krieg ich manchm die Frage
warum liest Du das weil man besser
vorher lesen sollte was die Leute wollen
WE bei Putin auch früher machen sollen
das stimme ich ihn voll zu geht gar
nicht das ist
völkisch die CDU der 80er das ist
radikales ged Mario fog das auch aus
Frage ja klar aber ja und ich bin es
auch irgendwie das deswegen merken Sie
das diese Frage immer wir sind da klipp
und klar ich würde mir wünschen dass
alle so klipp und klar sind in dieser
Frage zweiter
Punkt Bodo ramelo kriegt nur noch
Haushalte zusammen und das schon seit 2
D Jahren weil Mario Vogt mit ihm über
Haushalte verhandelt verantwortungsvolle
Opposition macht nur deswegen ist
thürgen noch regierbar es ist eine
Minderheitsregierung um daran zu
erinnern sie keine Mehrheit im Parlament
hat und deswegen macht die CDU in
Thüringen einen sehr
verantwortungsvollen Job und ich würde
mir wünschen wenn der gelegentlich
anerkannt würde und zum zweiten auch
wenn sie es nicht hören wollen wenn wir
uns mal die Frage stellen warum
eigentlich alle anderen Parteien der
demokratischen Mitte im
mittelostdeutschland faktisch keine
Rolle spielen zumindest mal vor allem in
Sachsen und in thürgen und das bringt
mich drittens dahin
zurück bringt mich drittens dahin zurück
jetzt Anfang des Jahres bei Wahlen im
September halte ich gar nichts davon
über Koalitionsfragen auf
Basis eine Koalitionsfrage
Entschuldigung ne die entscheidende
Frage ist gelingt es und ich bin
weiterhin fest davon überzeugt und ich
werde auch Wahlkampf machen wie viele
andere auch in diesen Landtagswahlen
weiterhin fest davon überzeugt dass es
gelingen kann gelingt es Vertrauen so
breit zurückzug gewinnen dass dass die
AFD sozusagen überflüssig wird als
dochum her dieses Vertrauen nicht wieder
zurückgewien
W vielleicht hat die Ampel den größten
Anteil daran das mag schon sein
vielleicht hätten sie sogar was davon
wenn die Ampel bis zum bis zur Bund bis
zu den Landtagswahlen im Herbst sich
auflöst wir vorher noch eine
Bundestagswahl haben vielleicht würde
das in den ostdeutschen Ländern der CDU
ein bisschen was aber das grundsätzliche
Problem das grundsätzliche Problem und
diese Stärke der AFD mit Werten über 30%
wird doch davon nicht zurück gehen sie
brauchen doch irgendwie einen
strategischen Ansatz um dieses Problem
dauerha glner erst und und dann her
Quent nur ganz kurz sie hören sich ein
bisschen an wie die SPD in den 90er
Jahren die und sie wissen das weil sie
sind spdmglied ne bin spdmglied und ich
bin vor allem 1990 geboren deswegen
haben sie die Zeit live erlebt und ich
nur in der Geschichte nachgelesen aber
altersrassismus eindeutig gegen mich
aber
egal mehr ein
Eingeständnis aber es ist interessant
die Regierung stand vor einer sehr sehr
groß Gren Herausforderung mit der
wiederereinigung vor allem als klar
wurde es klappt alles so nicht wie
gedacht erinnert ein so ein bisschen an
die letzten Jahre oh die schöne neue
klimawelt und wir transformieren unsere
Wirtschaft und wird super ganz viel
Wachstum ganz viel Investition jetzt
sieht man alles viel schwieriger und
kostet auch ganz viel Geld und was hat
die SPD damals gemacht die hat richtig
drauf gehauen Theo Weigel den ganzen Tag
verprügelt als
schuldenfinanzminister selber Vorschläge
wie man es wirklich finanzieren kann wie
man das gut hinbekommen kann hat die SPD
begrenzt gemacht und das ein bisschen so
bei Ihnen heute oder so habe ich das
Gefühl es ist wahnsinnig leicht momentan
draufzuhauen es ist sehr sehr schwer
konstruktive Vorschläge zu machen wie
man den Haushalt hinbekommt wie man die
ausbleibenden Investitionen hinbekommt
und darüber habe ich noch überhaupt
nichts gehört von ihnen und vielleicht
können wir da mal hinkommen weil ich
glaube das ist auch was die Menschen
interessiert und auch wenn wir über
Ostdeutschland reden die wollen wissen
wie geht's weiter ich den aber das ist
auch eine Frage Entschuldigung ganz kurz
her ist auch eine Frage dessen mit wem
koaliiert man also es kann ja sein dass
irgendwann nach einer dieser landag
Wahlen die CDU mit einer SED
Nachfolgepartei paktieren muss um eine
rechtsradikale Partei zu verhindernern
das ist doch die Situation über die wir
sprechen und deswegen ist das nicht
einfach irgendeine koalitionsverhandlung
und ist auch nicht trivial oder sehe ich
das Falsch das ist die Situation das ist
die Situation und ich meine wenn man
sich anschaut dass es auf der auf der
kommunalen und auch im Landtag das haben
sie ja beschrieben gibt es die
Zusammenarbeit in auf der praktischen
Ebene jetzt können Sie wieder anfangen
und wir können diskutieren was ist
eigentlich Zusammenarbeit wo hört das
auf W fängt das an aber die gibt es doch
pragmatisch in Wirklichkeit schon längst
und es gibt ja mittlerweile in Thüringen
auch gemeinsame Abstimmung mit der AFD
und der CDU gegen die Landesregierung
ETW in der haushaltsentscheidung das
wurde das wurde diskutiert ich will aber
noch mal auf ein anderen Punkt zurück
sie haben ja zurecht immer wieder
eingefordert dass wir uns doch mit den
eigentlichen Ursachen auseinandersetzen
sollten und dann sind wir doch wieder in
den parteipolitischen es ist die
Regierung die Regierung schon auch
interessant absolut aber ich meine das
dieilemmer das beschrieben wurde bei der
kämerichwahl das war ja noch zu anderen
Zeiten auch zu anderen koalitionszeiten
war da auch die Bundesregierung Schuld
nein so einfach kann man es sich nicht
machen wir haben eine
einen einen gewachsenen verdrust wir
haben diese Entfremdung diese
Wahrnehmung Menschen spüren das und das
sind das das betrifft ja nicht nur den
Diesel das betrifft auch den den
Wohnungsmarkt die Frage der der können
sich normal verdienende Familien noch
Eigentum überhaupt leisten das
funktioniert ja selbst in Thüringen wo
die Preise nicht so hoch sind gerade in
den Städten zunehmend schlecht das heißt
also nicht nur diese diese Kulturfragen
die damit verbunden sind die diskutiert
werden wenn wir an die tatsächlichen
Ursachen rankommen wollen dann müssen
wir uns anschauen dass wir einen
stabilen Satz an rechtsextrem
Einstellung haben in Thüringen seit
vielen Jahren gemessen im thüringmitor
bundesweit ist der im Vergleich vor zu 2
Jahren angestiegen auf 8% etwa der
Bevölkerung sagt ji Bielefeld mit einem
geschlossen rechtsextrem weltb in
Ostdeutschland ist es höher nicht alle
afdwler nicht alle die protestieren sind
sind rechtsextrem das ist schon ganz
klar aber wir müssen uns die Basis doch
vor Augen führen die dahinter steht und
das ist nicht nur die Regierung so etwas
wächst lange sowas war vielleicht auch
schon äh immer da und wird wird
mobilisiert damit müssen wir uns auch
auseinandersetzen und da muss ich
allerdings auch sagen Robert habek warn
vor diesen Gefahren in den Bereichen von
Demokratieförderung Rechtsextremismus
Prävention ist die jampel jetzt auch
nicht unbedingt über das hinausgegangen
was in der Vorgängerregierung war im
Gegenteil aber die beste Demokratie
Förderung und Extremismus Prävention ist
ja konkrete Politik ist doch eine
Wohnungsbaupolitik die dazu führt dass
bauen für autonomal wieder bezahlbar
wird das was immer gilt wenn ich mich
anstrenge wenn arbeiten gehe kann ich
für mich und meine Familie ein Häuschen
leisten das kann man durch Politik
verändern wieder herbeiführen die Frage
von sozialer Gerechtigkeit von Migration
auch das sind die Sachthemen das zweite
was dazu kommt was ich empfinde es ist
jetzt natürlich
aus aus Gesprächen sozusagen empfundene
empfundene
Stimmungen auch die da sind aber dass
viele eben sagen das hatten wir schon
mal dass man uns erzählt hat wir leben
irgendwie ein falsches Leben ne falsches
Auto falsche heizunges Gefühl dass
wieder einem versucht wird zu sagen dass
man falsches Leben führt und das andere
und das finde ich sehr spannend in den
Diskussionen wenn wenn ich in
mittelostdeutschland unterwegs bin dass
viele sagen das hatten wir schon mal das
dann System war eine Regierung war die
immer irgendwelche Planzahlen hatten
irgendwelche Ideen wo es lang gehen soll
und jeder der ein bisschen rechnen
konnte und Physik konnte wusste das kann
nicht das kann nicht funktionieren nee
aber dieses Empfinden z.B dass etwa in
der Klimaschutzpolitik CO2 dass die
Kohlekraftwerke in Ostdeutschland gerade
mehr laufen den je werden klimaneutrale
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden da
haben die Menschen gutes Gespür dafür
dass Rhetorik Bilder die gezeichnet
werden das was da so erzählt wird und
das was faktisch passiert nicht
zusammenpasst und mein Eindruck ist
manchmal dieser Sensibilität die ist aus
der historischen Erfahrung ja
Deutschland deutlich grö aber sie sagen
da gibt es noch so eine so eine
historische Allergie gegen die gegen die
SED und gegen die DDR da gibt's eine
Allergie dagegen das ein ein frage
deswegen noch mal meine Frage die
Zusammenarbeit mit der SED
nachfolgpartei mit der Linkspartei
schließen Sie die aus a oder nicht ich
habe gerade beschrieben wie Sie in
thüringgen tatsächlich etwa bei der HA
sie die aus sie findet doch statt sie
findet doch in Thüringen statt weil soll
ich was ausschließen was stattfindet
viel entscheidender ist do ein anderer
Punkt ich möchte ich möchte schließen
Sie eine Zusammenarbeit mit der Partei
von Sarah Wagenknecht aus ich also die
hat in ihren Umfragen aktuell 1% ich
weigere mich kann mehr werden ja klar
wenn wir jeden Tag in den landsendung
jeden Abend darüber reden und sie immer
einladen dann kann es mehr werden wenn
wir sehen ist eine 1% Partei und sie
einfach so nehmen wie sie ist
jetzt vielleicht ja aber wir reden immer
so viel über diese ganzen Phänomene bis
sie irgendwann groß sind ich komme immer
wieder zu einem Punkt zurück lass uns do
einfach die Probleme lösen Politik wenn
wir wenn wir nicht mehr daran glauben
und zweitens auch zeigen durch
Entscheidungen Politik kann ein
Unterschied machen der Wohnungspolitik
in deralp
gzner hat zum kann was ver kann was
verändern und Frau sielöckner hat gerade
zum Schluss noch eine konkrete Frage
gestellt sie wollten wissen wie es die
CDU dann macht persönlich wä gar noch
daran interessiert wo ist eigentlich
diese weil sie sagen Politik kann
gestalten wo sind denn eigentlich diese
sie hatten noch diese wunderbare Idee
10% auf Erbschaftssteuer ne im Dezember
FL kam das von
flattx und jetzt habe ich wieder
nachgelesen und noch mal und noch mal
ich lese ja nachts immer das cduprogrm
ein gutes Werk ja genau und deswegen
schlafe ich sehr wenig da stehen viele
interessante Sachen aber aber ich suche
irgendwie ist das weggezaubert
verschwunden wer war der ja na das ist
ja erst zum einen ein Grundsatzprogramm
und zum zweit aber sie sind do in der
wohlstandskommission ja ja ich über die
erbschasteuer das war drin ich wollte n
sagen über die Erbschaftsteuer zu reden
finde ich in also wir haben in
Deutschland W ich noch eben den warum
hab wir warum haben wir darüber geredet
Einkommensungleichheit sind wir in
Deutschland durch die Sozialsysteme
durch Steuersystem relativ gut eine
relative Gleichheit absolut die gibt's
nie auch im internationalen Vergleich zu
schaffen vermögensungleichheit nicht vor
allem durch die Niedrigzinsphase die
lange sind viele und das ist auch eine
Form von Leistung lososen
Vermögenszuwachs einfach reicher
geworden Immobilien Aktien ohne
irgendwas zu tun und wir haben
gleichzeitig hunderttausende Kinder die
jedes Jahr geboren werden in Familien
hier rein wo von Anfang an klar ist die
werden in ihrem ganzen Leben
wahrscheinlich nie 30 50 000 10 000 € an
Vermögen sehen und da darüber zu reden
was ist eigentlich was kann man
eigentlich tun was sind die richtigen
Instrumente Vermögenssteuer ist es
sicher nicht sondern bei der
erbschasteuer zu schauen wie kann man
Anpassung machen für D ich eine legitime
Debatte
die fen wir in der CDU auch weiter ähm
was uns wichtig ist ist warum ist das
jetzt raus warum pas dasich auf diese
schöne flattex Idee 10% auf alles auch
auf Tiernahrung einfach für alle weil
die meisten schönen Ideen ja zurecht
noch das aber hinterher haben uns ist
eins sehr sehr wichtig und das muss
gewährleistet sein dass
Familienunternehmen in der
generationenübergabe in der Nachfolge
ohne Substanzverlust weiter gegeben
werden können und das braucht
konzeptionell noch etwas mehr Arbeit das
ist nämlich leichter gesagt als getan ja
war das ein Schnellschuss oder wer hat
ihn gekillt es ist nicht gekillt die
Debatte geht ja weiter die
Debatte wir hab gemeinsam entschieden
übrigens auch aus auf meine mitintiative
hin warum habe ich die genommen weil ich
gemerkt habe dass eine Zeit wo so viele
Unternehmen vor allem
Familienunternehmen total verunsichert
sind 250 Milliarden Investitionen
letztes Jahr aus Deutschland
rausgeflossen ist kaum jemand investiert
in Deutschland ist keine gute
Zeit um jetzt beim Thema
erbschaftssteuergrad Familienunternehmen
noch mal zusätzlich zu verunich und
deswegen führen wir führen die Debatte
auch mit den Verbänden mit den
Unternehmen weiter ich möchte das
Familienunternehmen wir möchten das
Familienunternehmen weitergegeben werden
können und gleichzeitig finde ich den
Ansatz flattex wie Sie es nennen
einheitssteuersatz zu haben weiterhin
ein richtigen das Verfassungsgericht
wird wahrscheinlich sehr bald noch mal
die jetzige
erbschaftssteuerregelung ein Urteil dazu
Fällen viele rechnen damit dass sie
wieder sagen wird so wie es jetzt ist
ist verfassungswidrig und da möchten wir
gerne ein durchgerechnetes
funktionierendes Konzept haben daran
arbeiten wir weiter und dazu gehört auch
ja der einheitliche Steuersatz bei
gleichzeitigen Schutz der
familienunternehmenner Politik kann
gestalten kann den Unterschied machen
was würde das bedeuten 10% auf auf große
Vermögen die aus Vererbung kommen ja es
ist tatsächlich schwierig das aufs Jahr
zu sagen solange man nicht die Regelung
feststellt wie man das bei
Familienunternehmen streckt erstmal
vielleicht vorweg ich finde es super
super mutig und toll dass sie dieses
Thema ansprechen ich weiß wie schwierig
das ist auch gerade gerade beim CDU
Klientel aber da haben wir in
Deutschland einen großen Missstand jedes
Jahr wden ungefähr 200 Milliarden
vererbt im Moment habe ich das richtig
im Kopf ja und also wenn man jetzt
versucht ich meine es geht spezifisch
momentan um diese große Ausnahme für
Betriebsvermögen die werden über 20
Millionen durchschnittlich schätzt man
mit 0,29% besteuert 0,29 weil viele
komplett verschont werden es ist
wahnsinnig schwierig das gut
hinzubekommen aber 0 29% können sie
niemand erklären können Sie auch niemand
erklären der heute 200 000 oder 500 000
erbt oder eine Immobilie und dar der
bezahlt wie viel zahlen muss na kommt
drauf an wie sie es am Ende hinkriegen
aber so 15% ungefähr und ab 20 Millionen
sind wir bei 0,29 das ist aber nicht
also das ist Schnitt der Schnitt ja das
ist der der geschätzte schnitt man kann
es nicht ganz genau sagen weil es
erst die ersten Auswertungen darüber
gibt wie viel in dem neuen reformierten
Regime ganz ausgenommen sind deswegen
ist es eine Schätzung vom Netzwerk
Steuergerechtigkeit aber dass das da was
nicht passt das ist glaube ich relativ
klar eine sehr elegante Lösung ist dass
man eine stille Einlage macht dass der
Staat Teilhaber des Unternehmens wird
und dann sich der Eigentümer entscheiden
kann wann er den Staat rauskauft so hat
man keinen Druck kein liquiditätsverlust
und kann auch sagen der bleibt einfach
dabei könnten sie eigentlich so so
machen so brauchen sich die Unternehmen
keine großen Sorgen machen und könnten
das Thema gleich weiter verfolgen ja
super das dann machen wir das doch bei
nächster Gelegenheit Lösung Beanz
gefunden